Hausa Gomez my spirit path welcome back
to course party chapter 3 I'm in Italy
as you can see I had to replay the
entire game from because I didn't have
it on this computer and I thought I'd
saved the safe but I friend Landon so I
had a lot of fun clicking X it was fun
you didn't have to do anything but here
we are and my soul with slice of itself
wait what the hell is she
I would say the same view Mitsuki scene
bison ah [ __ ] I'm shut up at all why are
they always involved I sure that's
that's lovely I love that which school
oh damn hammer
we got something now Don oh god what I
stretch my thigh what is this who's this
gonna be me not oh boy Donna I don't
know why we did good
look what is happening
what is this Kyla
ah she said so didn't I oh the Dulwich
Ethan good screw though that's still
what Nance
what that fight what is it
oh nice ah
I guess some people like it rough huh oh
Jesus
I think I seen a point like this once
Sanna all stop he said I get it
there prettily murdered oh damn what is
this oh [ __ ]
don't make me play as her he'll die
sniffle
so if she's outside shouldn't she just
be able to escape
what a [ __ ] Syrian hey I'm so confused
Oh God Oh God
uh but I don't like this Oh
oh [ __ ] it's her what what oh Jesus
this is great boys acting out okay
answer
I like the background on the phone the
foss what am I supposed to do I don't
get it shut up no I can't I can do
anything
[ __ ] it's now me Jesus I love pants too
Oh God not this again
this [ __ ] gay man how I play from
here so I guess we're gonna find out
what really went down
okay no dog honey who said that who say
hey oh [ __ ] it's her what does you are
for this Shinda you did this
that's fantastic what the MoDOT you are
professional panel this but had me sorry
sometimes like go too early of this
because I don't speak Japanese so I
don't even know but you know what's
going on
it fries don't freeze on me now this is
very bad very bad indeed
watch oh oh no gasps oh mama no
cigarettes no cigar
oh so Rebecca no Roy days so no no no in
a hurry Tom oh no ma SE semo Kassar a
poker amamori tomini towpath take a knee
poor johan odo cotan yaga yooo aron
dissimilar to Moya's pony Activa soccer
on Jota new chick tauriel
no no yo Joe Monica possession or Tony
cheetah yokel Atari Jojo azam azam
Edessa
everything is horrible about this game
day turning gala more I'm not the sky oh
well she will whatever what she will do
then another aqua no mama
Sheena muddy dirty Butchie oh thanks
thanks Barret appreciate it that's what
I wanted to hear right now
oh okay so she ran away you're done said
well that's not bumble I don't
oh now I get out [ __ ] oh ah no don't die
now me please she already heard her fate
oh no no nope oh come on
even though it's just a couple of pics
pixel is still disgusting
Oh God study is Amancio key and now he
found Escanaba oh yes listen to sake of
spirit
it does he wouldn't I need to do good
not you poor Naomi she's crying in her
bonnet
let's be honest we don't probably do the
same [ __ ] that's chapter 3 for you
I hear that the most [ __ ] up parts are
yet to come so that's comforting yoku
not gonna cut the law oh yeah and we
wanted to play with these two at salchow
country declared a seminary Jiva tenbu
de q good coconuts no tama sigue Sachi
high tech or any you cannae noni yeah we
know all the peoples slow system Oh Toni
Marie she bangs oh yeah mi ke Taji ugh
she really not a roller Nino des Eaux
logic oh she idiotic she Alba Sione Luka
siento almos cachito itani sakura-con
Olek uno y Karina credit Oh
don't hang up
sounds scary here would be yeah it
sounds scary but we have to try anyway
Gaudio tiger or attach all the tiny
dents wrote a code us the center yeah
yes'm
there are all such good people that
doesn't help anyone else you can I be
who Gina jr. hey tiny Chrissy
Amado Kim is Regina so loco o'clock Doga
Knox's Anita gray now we will lose it
all right dad a motion detector nitrogen
donor Ganges galante you Otomo solo
kokoro sorry gamma-delta much dedicated
arepa granules Clicquot to a taking
actively boom a was Costa yo Mitch pico
de Vecchio camiseta
a dad is not an idea hey being a blue
flame seems pretty alright with me
compared to everything else is happening
Doh so about final girl
una cosa cheat on you yoga or todo mundo
que yes Tony Hawk sensei aminos
abba-zaba Tochigi Gucci gammas Katara
Omaha kini animo Dorinda gain ka he yo
Gucci conclusion Aras Soto you dare como
signal sword a inca cachet
all right so we already know that the
little girl is gonna die and that's not
very nice at all it's actually pretty
shitty I can I can't believe that happen
in the last episode when you realize
that splattered pool of blood was her
this is like what yeah oh god it's first
time is really this toric oh [ __ ] so I
really like Satoshi I've been waiting
for him to you
oh how the hell are you gonna make it I
mean I know it's not but you got yeah oh
[ __ ] screaming tonight Tony's daughter
Cindy how can the aki-nee tell ya can't
you stop stay back he okay
almost I mean look
come on you just had a pep talk exactly
you go yeah
guys over that sure you cuz all good
enough ha ha ha I'm really glad I
managed to get their voice acting
working cuz it's really really awesome
oh sorry
a message has been painstakingly carved
into the floor bar next to it seemingly
with fingernails along of course kill me
please kill me please kill me please
kill me please kill me can't take
anymore
can't take anymore can't take Emma let
me out no thanks that sounded like a bad
Justin Bieber song they're all bad
um alright let's check this out why do I
keep saying good job me there's copper
all out on the ground decomposing
rapidly it's cluttering a letter in its
anthem at recess following dear brother
I regret that we couldn't see any other
again before my death but I no longer
had the energy to move and I'm so
desperately thirsty my tongues started
swelling up like a sponge and it keeps
cutting off my air I'd find it's
fascinating if it would stop nearly
suffocating me I just want something to
drink
anything heck I'd even drink that scary
orange juice from the back of the fridge
right about now hmm maybe that's a clue
but there's not a drop of anything to be
found
I'm so thirsty it's actually making me
nauseous right now I just hope at least
you can make it out of here alive if
anyone else finds this my name is
Kirikou Mata Maura from Amazon blah blah
blah are you serious
I hate that in RPGs ok
the shelf the Ballad of bad evil bunny
book of beetle wings nice great library
um I was thinking about that too if
you're stuck in this place for long
obviously a lot of people would have to
starve to death oh this is 2a we've been
in this it's right now it's the same
it's cool how it's the same school but
it keeps changing this is where the
teacher almost died I want to see you
again it goes told me
apparently you were brought here too but
we're in different spaces Emma though
we're in the same school I can't see you
why did this happen to us I shouldn't be
here I should be in my math I class at
prep school my sister's going to be
really mad at me for skipping I don't
think she'd believe this excuse even if
I told her though I like how that's what
she's worries about I feel like if I can
ever find you I'll be able to get out of
here alive I don't know why but if we
really are in the same school and I know
there must be a way to get in contact
with you and I'm gonna find it
so maybe the notes work I don't know
ain't nobody knows I'm gonna have to go
back there's nothing for us there
oh god there's nothing else is it no I
noticed when I replayed chapter 1 that
if you miss some stuff you go you you
get the bad ending and if you get the
bad ending you have to replay everything
so let's make sure we go through all of
it well know
she Donal the game just mixes cute with
extreme detest car and it's just like
what the [ __ ]
that contrast won't be okay you you
gotta say die job do yoga Tomy nada
Kyra's oh that face seemed poised to
know what he got see their car yeah
that's not very comforting yes hey I saw
Joey toga quiere taka yeah porygon I can
i yes
you gotta be strong side OG e mono me
JRE sukhasana it's me Nami mo da quadi
hood I did oh come here
Hayek Miss Kitty erinite oh well we
already know we can't find each other
but I'd like to believe him and now me
Wilson survived together I was like the
music hey they're rusted bucket on the
ground it's empty it was an empty it was
an empty he's gonna pee in that bucket
isn't he
let's find a block there should be a
block here right no hmm
there it is alright we just have to get
it from the other side don't you worry
don't you worry bro cuz booties has got
up Oh God we're [ __ ] science a child
spirit obese old-fashioned yoga
Munakata son die Judah ok should be down
here right what uh-oh
no bueno alright we're gonna have to
find a way to get that well [ __ ] we're
not gonna do that
god damn it we're gonna die um why did
she go
here maybe doubt it I don't like this
well maybe she'll oh you know what we
should say see they have the ham circle
or face cams why can I have circular
face can I do whatever one thing every
work up right as their I prize
I can have it [ __ ] I read this anyway
he's walking on his own here indoors
silikal is it really I don't notice it
oh okay we'll use the same trick yeah
ambush a board now your [ __ ] you girls
you look at you okay
mental picture got it nailed it
that means this means we're gonna have
to split up the last time we were fine
probably means this time we're not gonna
be fine
I don't like this I don't think it's a
good idea what if we take two buckets
and puts it's over I think we should use
the bucket and then pee in it
all right I took a good mantle yes Mike
would it squish some update I did god I
don't like this can't he just move those
chairs it's a bad better idea Nigel
signal yo hey Cohen what are you doing
ah yeah no don't don't do it there has
to be another way
yes I promise
huh you bet
you betcha I don't think so
I don't I don't like this Prez I really
don't this game really plays tricks on
you I got it grabbed it teleporting boy
cute she did it she's so good I'm so
proud
Bhumika Chawla
stop-start Sunita's oh look at all this
go
she's stuck now what is it Chesapeake
don't tell me she has to pee
oh okay you know what
you can nobody how would he not be a
die-hard when will I care s that he boy
hotel or dad give it a sniff
is she gonna drug me is she farting
there Oh John I'm waiting on you it all
know who's you know a Bissell huh
yes it's an angel of limbo we are the
customer chiku pop she can call my mom
bacon Adama yes yes that makes sense
Garrett ah that feels ah de Janeiro yo
oh my MA Tina
he wants to protect make it caramel by
Donna please scatterbrain oh she doesn't
trust that quark smoke our demo food
retailers and I got really shitty man
just take it of course knock up da
Jack how do you do what caramel can do
more than that yes I remember really
here tell me please
it tastes good you can use it as shampoo
MO no ego anymore no what is it now we
just get we actually acquire it as an
item maybe spread since we're poor like
gonna use it then all right oh god I'm
getting like stop it stop it stop it
why playing an old my first computer
all right you know what just in case he
crashes I'm gonna have to get 60 yes and
the cow let's give gum breasts oh no
we're gonna have to bring the plane
right you're gonna be strong
you got you got do okay what is that
don't I wouldn't stand next to freaking
it so what opposite day earthquake what
the [ __ ] oh please really scare me
because we don't have them in Sweden
sand whenever I hear about them I'm like
what do i do what am I supposed to do it
just feels like if one happens I'm
basically fine there's Geller made them
young all right looking closely holding
a letter bode fingers so sorry if only I
didn't discover that stupid charm yes so
they all were brought here by that charm
that that's stupid vlogging girl posted
online god damn it
I'm never gonna [ __ ] with any chumps any
with your boards anything added and you
missed the final nail in this the end of
school you're still here then you'll
always be thanks note of optimism you
bros pointed out that Japanese people
take off their shoes before they suicide
that's a thing apparently
so I guess some mass suicide happen here
I don't know and I don't want to know
there's a girl's there we should not go
near him I don't trust him
it's probably the girls from before it
does look different here
heavy cabinets collapse across the floor
hair the board surrounded our creaking
under its weight by Montgomery it would
be far too risky
yeah damn it oh hey girl
are you done oh it's so cute it's so
good I like it yeah it's so cute you
look like a Disney girl or something
buddy that was in six hours I was pretty
fun
mmm that's good can I just finish up
okay let's keep going
I'm okay I almost touched it why I don't
know I I was amazed the temperature and
the corner what Oh God
you pay oh god don't kill me please oh
[ __ ] she's coming he's coming around
great the dirty house left behind by the
soul filthy disgusting carbon dust they
pulse it back a made of Titian yet one
was scrubbing cleared well where isn't
in eternity permit of salvation for the
Lord death wash off Oh
English yes I speak English I don't
trust this game this game plays with
your feelings I'm on my god 24/7 while
I'm playing this game so technically
okay we're back here now this is where
her blood will be splattered oh god I
don't like this what is happening why is
it so Jack science man [ __ ] science lab
it can only not be good things and the
same slave in here can we bring this
play - no ah oh oh no let's check this
first don't be greedy the skeleton
remains some primo stoner arse phone
across the floor pin - what's left a
very school uniform is didn't ID name
tag Saint Marion mikuma Sugoi Sugoi
so guy there's something sparkly graphic
- yes unknown key I don't like unknown
keys because I don't know where they're
unknown well since stuff sorry
oops I'm comets here all you want I
don't care
bad a spear strikes again why do so
what's up ah boy take die isn't there
bathrooms in here somewhere
oh Sokka so Konica biotic achar Gaara yo
yo
yes perfect you go see no mean you
doctor o Nanak Arthur I obey oh I don't
like this press
I really really really don't like this
no you gotta go gotta negra what just go
Akiko Katayama
that's why sure you just wanted to know
you perv
okay what do we do while you wait I
usually pick up my iphone I don't have
my iPhone I guess I'll do the little
veins hello my little sis is doing the
potty dance there we go it works every
time
Mujica well then it looks like we'll
have to pee in the bucket after Earth
why not what is it
what's it what is it I guess I like to
check oh my god
Dakota seriously this place is wrecked
why don't you just pee in the floor I
guess she's a tiny girl she doesn't want
to origin Marie de nada de Soto's also
come on De Luca oh ha ha
Norma's story gone on to cats Katara in
Ghana ah it's boarded shut maybe we can
find a nail god damn it ah bucket time
if it's bucket time baby
I knew it because it was filled with PB
four words I need someone had to pee in
it alright let's head back wait now this
is not where we came from hi chat
everything good salùte salads ooh
I like how it all of a sudden just get
dark it's [ __ ] great where's my
bucket
give me my bucket after walk all this
way if there was any other character
that had to pee I'd be like no [ __ ] off
you'll find a [ __ ] bathroom that says
say SAP cap ikat kind of find that
bucket and we're gonna pay you Nick
oh no no I just realized something
remember in the beginning when they were
talking about that they were thirsty and
they would literally drink anything well
I'm not gonna say any more than that but
I just I don't know maybe I'm getting
ahead of myself here well there is no
other bathrooms we already know this but
everybody what she want from me
I'll get it what does he want oh [ __ ] I
should not have been it Oh God
Oh God why did I do that Oh God
a [ __ ] sound oh god what did i do
today I got goose nip Steve you're not
supposed to do that Oh God
oh sure we're [ __ ]
oh no the caramel
I got distracted by the caramel he
sniffs the caramel he [ __ ] loves
karamja 45 the caramel said Yves life
really awesome oh you go Emily oh my no
nobody oh I gotta go min ha ha ha no
kena oh I don't need to hear that all
right we made it
I'm sorry buzz I have to end this
episode here I'm asking as you know I'm
in Italy internet is so slow here so I'm
gonna have to upload it during night cuz
otherwise it literally takes like 21
hours to upload a video which is insane
especially this long and then I know you
bros are used to long episodes now so
that's what I try to do nevertheless
thank you boys for watching this episode
I'll see you tomorrow with a new one
hopefully um so thank you for
understanding that it said it's easy for
me to provide all things that I do when
when I'm here so yeah but thankfully me
like thank you for subscribing and being
a bro and I'll see you tomorrow
dancing boys love you